i'm nina dobrev and i'm back doing the
wired auto complete interview
this account is googling if it comes in
a paper
[Music]
did nina doperev it's a long one
ever date anyone from
you guys asking these hard-hitting
questions that i'm not gonna answer
i mean that one's pretty obvious yes yes
i did damon stefan one of the lockwoods
matt elena dated matt as well
broke his heart broke all their hearts
actually i was a heartbreaker did nina
dobrev
audition for twilight
did i
oh god so i remember reading the book
becoming obsessed with twilight wanting
to audition for it when they started
doing that but they didn't care about me
they didn't want me to audition but hey
i got vampire diaries so it all worked
out did nina dobrev
win lip-sync battle wow you guys
i did not win the lip-sync battle
and it's still
i still carry that around to this day
tim tebow
you know what you did
did nina dobrev
die in real life people were wondering
about this who thinks i died
do i even need to answer this question
i'm here
next board
how nina dobrev how did nina dobrev
and julian huff meet we have a mutual
hair stylist and friend named rihanna
capri everybody knows that your hair
stylist is your therapist like you're
sitting in their chair complaining about
your life i was doing that with with
rihanna and telling her about my life
julian was doing the same thing and i
think rihanna was kind of sick of
hearing us
to her about it so
she was like you know what you're not
paying me enough i'm gonna put you two
together you guys can talk about all
this and figure it out she knew
that we would get along and we did and
the rest is history how does nina dobrev
no vin diesel vin and i did a movie
together called
triple x return of xander cage no it is
not a porno it's an action movie i play
uh a
tech nerd that
is very awkward
how does nina dobrev
know bulgarian
known bulgarian
the way i known
bulgarian
is uh i
was born in bulgaria so bulgarian is my
first language i remember growing up
when we moved to canada eventually and
my parents got really concerned that i
was losing my bulgarian
so they started insisting that we speak
bulgarian in the household and i
remember as a kid being so annoyed that
they were making me do this because all
my cool friends in school
spoke english and it wasn't until i
became an adult that i really really
really valued the fact it's really
useful to have
the muscle memory and
knowledge and and sort of exercise that
to be able to speak multiple languages
is really great
so i'm really grateful thanks mom and
dad yeah okay don't shove it in my face
i already know
you guys okay over there what's nina
dobrev
uh oh
what's nina dobrev doing now
i'm currently in a studio filming this
interview what movies are nina dobrev
in on netflix i'm doing a movie right
now for netflix that is called love hard
it is just coming out now you might see
my dog
mrs maverick in one of the shots so try
to spot her what's nina dobrev's
this might be a problem i think it said
zodiac before i ripped it off the sheet
i think i'm uh
aquarius capricorn
sagittarius combo
don't really know what that means i've
had it explained to me but you know like
in one ear out the other kind of a vibe
what degrassi was nina dobrev in
i was in
degrassi the next generation the show
with drake and cheney grimes lauren
collins and all the other talented
wonderful cast members we definitely
stay in touch
probably not as much as
i'd like to but
whenever we do run into each other it's
always a good time what nina dobrev what
nina dobrev
eats in a day that's an interesting why
it's funny to me but people want to know
what i eat i eat a lot of things i eat
um healthy some days i eat really bad
some other days i eat all kinds of
yummy like vegan burgers i like making
gluten-free pastas i like cooking a lot
which is fun and also
time-consuming but it feels sort of like
it's a great way for me to unwind at the
end of the day
what is nina dobrev
what is my favorite color
kind of changes red has always been my
favorite color in general over the years
it's been pretty consistently red
but then you know something about like a
lilac not really like it's like a bluey
purple
muted purple color
really into that for some reason i said
that last time oh my god i said that
last time it's like it's red is really
my favorite color what is nina dobrev
favorite song
i've really been into oldies lately i go
on spotify and kind of
select old playlist like whatever they
suggest but also there's this song
called petals that's out right now that
i'm really into
what was nina
dobrev
for halloween one year i was harry ron
and hermione
underneath the invisibility cloak i made
that one myself i ordered this like
invisibility cloak and got
a clothing hanger printed out a photo of
ron and harry
and glued it to the clothing hangar so
they were like right next to me and then
i had a wig and did my makeup to look
like hermione and i had like a little
school girl harry potter outfit on that
was fun one year i
was
a star is born
the movie but
differently i built like a crib and i
was a baby and i had a star on my head i
think so i was a star that was born get
it when i post it people usually are
like oh that's
that's really we get it adorable but
when you're out at the party people just
look at me and they're like
what's happening i had a pacifier in my
mouth and i think i had a bottle but
instead of putting milk in the bottle i
filled it with tequila or maybe it was
white wine i can't remember one year i
was billy eilish her green hair was
really popular in the nails i had these
like crazy long nails for once people
knew what i was pretty immediately but
the nails my god i don't know how she
does it day to day
i mean
she must have like three assistants i
put a lot
of thought and energy and time into
making my costumes so please keep
googling this
where
to buy
nina dobrev's wine i'm happy you asked
you can buy my wine fresh vine wine my
favorite wine is the chardonnay the cab
the pinot and the rose
they're delicious
who did nina dobrev
go to prom with
wouldn't you guys like to know i went to
prom with my high school sweetheart we
we
yeah we why am i getting so flustered
all of a sudden talking about
um his name is eric he was a little
cutie and we went to prom together
and
maybe the fun times a long time ago gosh
i feel so old almost a while ago is nina
dobrev
right or left-handed
wouldn't you like to know
i'm right-handed is there like a term
not for ambidextrous but football
dexterous is that a thing because i can
write with my feet but no one's googled
that but they're about to a lot are nina
dobrev and paul wesley still friends yes
my friends i would like to report that
the dubs and i are homies
i love his wife my dog and his dog
play like best friends that have known
each other forever and i actually see
him a lot love that guy
does nina dobrev
ships delana or delena you guys you keep
asking these questions and you know i'm
not going to answer them because i don't
want to alienate half of my amazing
loving fans
next question which nina dobrev
character are you
um
i don't know if i am all of one
character i think there are
bits and pieces of me in many of the
roles that i've played i've i feel like
i've learned a lot about myself through
all the movies and tv shows and
roles that i've had the pleasure of
playing
and then i've also learned what not
to do and be because of all the
characters and tv shows that i've been
in i've also played some pretty horrible
people that um
that i don't want to be like
you know you know what i'm saying
the true fans who have seen all my
things that you know what i'm talking
about
all right the last one
oh my god that was the last one
we're done
thank you guys so much for tuning in
i hope that you enjoyed this and
i sincerely hope that you keep
googling weird things about me so that
we can do this again i want to come back
for a
third time
see you guys on the next
one damn it it didn't hit the thing this
time
it's gonna be awkward
gosh